[Music]
floral cape epic tiara ruby earrings
j.lo ruled the runway show owning every
inch of her royal look
[Music]
perfection with just one glitch as jlo
stepped into her water taxi headed to
the fashion show you could see her
cape's price tag still attached
[Music]
j hud who looked glam and gold performed
and called it a fairy tale weekend in
venice
more star power oscar winner helen
mirren enroute in a gold bodice vanessa
bryant gorgeous in teal and sharing this
video with sierra that's vin diesel
popping his head in his boat is lit
zoe saldana was stunning in all black
and bibi rexa smoldered in silver
metallic another highlight proud celeb
parents
diddy was a super proud dad watching his
three daughters chance delilah and jesse
walk the runway in fact the music mogul
was so overwhelmed he wrote words can't
explain love
and heidi klum's daughter 17-year-old
lenny was a vision in blue as she
arrived on a gondola heidi shared video
of lenny on the runway and called this
moment the smile when she sees mom love
that
earlier mother and daughter twinned in
silver sequins lenny called it matching
with mommy are you so proud i'm super
proud it's just weird you know when all
of a sudden you know it's your child and
all of a sudden she's a young woman like
going to work
it's crazy what kind of advice could you
give to a future model like her always
just go with your gut don't let people
tell you what to do always do you